everyone knows it's a good idea to keep
your application dependencies up-to-date
kubernetes and docker can make these
updates much easier as you can build a
new container with the updated
dependencies and deploy it with relative
ease
just like your application dependencies
kubernetes
is constantly getting new features and
security updates so the underlying nodes
and kubernetes infrastructure needs to
be kept up to date as well in this
episode of kubernetes best practices
let's take a look at how google
kubernetes engine can make upgrading
your kubernetes cluster painless
[Music]
when it comes to upgrading your cluster
there are two parts that they need to be
upgraded the masters and the nodes the
masters need to be updated first and
then the nodes can follow let's see how
to upgrade both using google kubernetes
engine google kubernetes engine will
automatically upgrade the master as
point releases are released however it
usually won't upgrade to a new version
for example
1.7 to 1.8 automatically when you're
ready to upgrade to a new version you're
going to click the upgrade master button
in the gke console however you may have
noticed that the dialog box has two
following changing the master version
can result in several minutes of control
plane downtime during that period you'll
be unable to edit this cluster Wow okay
so when the master goes down for the
upgrade deployments and services and all
that normal kubernetes stuff will
continue to work as expected however
anything that requires the kubernetes
api will stop working so this means cube
GTL will start working applications that
use the kubernetes api to get from
information and about the cluster will
start working and basically you can't
make any change to the cluster while
it's being upgraded so how do you update
the master with zero downtime while the
standard zonal gke cluster can only have
one master backing them you can actually
create regional clusters that provide
multi zone high availability masters so
when creating your cluster be sure to
select the regional option and that's it
your nodes and masters will
automatically be created in three zones
and the masters will be behind a load
balanced IP address so the kubernetes
api will continue to work during an
upgrade when upgrading nodes there are a
few different strategies that you can
use there's two that I want to focus on
rolling updates and migration using node
pools the simplest way to update your
kubernetes nodes is using a rolling
update this is the default upgrade
mechanism that GK uses to update your
nodes a rolling update works in the
following way
one by one a node is drained in cordoned
so that there are no more pods
running on that note then the note is
deleted and the new node is created with
the updated kubernetes version once that
node is up and running the next note is
updated and so on and so forth until all
the nodes are updated you can let gke
manage this process for you completely
by enabling automatic node upgrades on
the node pool now if you don't select
this option the gke dashboard will alert
you when it upgrade is available just
click the link follow the prompts and
you'll begin your rolling update it's
important to make sure your pods are
managed by a replica set deployment
state we'll set or something similar
standalone pods won't be rescheduled so
while the rolling update is simple to
perform on gke it does have a few
drawbacks one drawback is you actually
get one less node of capacity in your
cluster while it's updating that node is
being taken out of commission right but
this issue is easily solved by scaling
up your node pool to add extra capacity
and then scaling it back down once the
upgrade is finished
also the fully automated nature of the
rolling update makes it easy to do but
you have less control over the process
so if something goes wrong and you hit a
rollback it takes time to roll back to
the old version because you had to stop
the rolling update and then undo it so
now let's look at how I can use multiple
node pools to upgrade your cluster so
instead of upgrading the active node
pool as you would with the rolling
update you create a brand new fresh node
pool wait for all the nodes to be
running and then migrate workloads over
one node at a time because you're
running these commands yourself you have
more control over the migration process
but gke still managing the notes for you
so let's assume that our kubernetes
cluster has three vm's right now you can
see the nodes with the get node command
to create a new node pull with the name
pool to run the following command
remember to customize this command so
the new node pool is the same as the old
pool you can also use the GUI to create
a new node pool if you want check out
the link for more information
so now if you check the note you'll
notice that there's three more nodes in
the new pool name however the pods will
still be on the old notes so let's move
them over we need to move pots to the
new note pool let's move over one note
at a time in a rolling fashion first
cordon each of the old nodes
this will prevent new pie's from being
scheduled onto them once all the old
notes are cordoned pots can only be
scheduled onto the new nodes this means
you can start to remove pods from the
old nodes and kubernetes will
automatically schedule them onto the new
nodes then we need to drain each node so
this will delete all the pods on that
node after you drain a node make sure
the new pods are up and running before
moving on to the next one if you have
any issues during migration on cord into
and then cordon and drain the new pool
and so the pods will automatically get
rescheduled back to the old pool once
all the pods are safely rescheduled it's
just time to delete the old pool replace
default pool with the pool you want to
delete by using google kubernetes engine
you can keep your kubernetes cluster up
to date with just a few clicks I highly
recommend using gke regional clusters
for the high availability masters and
using automatic node upgrades to have a
hassle free upgrade experience if you
need extra control for your node updates
using node pools gives you that control
without giving up the advantages of a
managed platform that gke gives you if
you're not using a managed service like
gke you can still use a rolling update
or node pools method with your own
cluster to upgrade notes the difference
is you need to manually add the new
nodes to your cluster and perform the
master upgrades yourself which can be
tricky I'll see you on the next episode
of kubernetes best practices
you